want to pull up this story from the post
millennial breaking Elon Musk welcomes
ligma and Johnson back to Twitter so
these are these are two employee a
former employees they're getting their
jobs back congratulations to ligma and
Johnson for uh uh getting your job check
no I'm just kidding these guys they
hoaxed the media walked out of Twitter
HQ carrying boxes and then claimed that
they had been fired the post millennial
now reports in an unexpected
heartwarming move Elon Musk welcomed
back quote former employees ligma and
Johnson to Twitter headquarters today
Rahul ligma and Daniel Johnson are
fictitious names used by two pranksters
who were able to dupe mainstream media
into believing that they were woke
Twitter employees who had just been
fired not everybody was uh it wasn't
just the mainstream media that fell for
it I I of course did a report on it
um mentioning they thought that it was a
hoax so uh turns out it was but the
reason I bring this story up while we're
dealing with the insane rules of YouTube
and the the ridiculous policies that are
that are it's impossible to adhere to
I've forgotten so for a long period I
was getting I wasn't getting demonetized
anymore
as soon as we get to election season all
the videos are demonetized and it's very
very obvious here's what happens
YouTube my understanding is they use
third-party monetization Checkers or
whatever
they said that my politics talk talking
about like the polls are here and here
was dangerous or gratuitous violence
demonetized okay I then have to contact
my rep at Google and say hey they're
doing it again and they go oh sorry
about that we'll fix it my response is
no no not sorry about it we'll fix it at
a certain point when you you have an
observable pattern of Twitter's I'm
sorry of YouTube's contractors lying to
strip ads off the content you have got a
breach of contract and I shouldn't have
to then go to someone at Google and be
like oh by the way your guys are lying
again yeah now all my videos
automatically demonetized 24 hours after
the videos get all of their hits then
they get remonetized which of course
leaves me with barely any money my
income on YouTube by the way went down
one-fourth of what it used to be in
these key particular times as my
viewership has skyrocketed more than it
ever has before but my income is is at
its lowest that it has on on YouTube
what's going on there I mean obviously
it's a dirty game it's just ridiculous
Instagram right now reinstated a warning
whenever you sign up to my account out
whenever you try to follow me on
Instagram at lukewe or change our net it
will tell you do you sure you want to
follow this guy he spreads a lot of fake
news what kind of fake news am I
starting I'm spreading memes and and and
uh one of our guests just tweeted the
photo of this warning telling people not
to sign there right I can't even search
for you yeah look we are change yeah on
Instagram and it wouldn't surprise me if
they banned me to the point where you
can't even find me uh but there's a
photo that I just tweeted on Twitter
showing specifically do not follow this
guy he's he's spreading this information
I spread memes that's that's all I do
memes that you could interpret in many
different you should you should you
should sue for defamation yeah
absolutely absolutely because it's it's
this account has repeatedly posted false
information that was reviewed by
independent fact Checkers or went
against our community guidelines I think
you should file a lawsuit let's do it if
there's a lawyer let's do this right now
uh hit me up I know a guy no well let's
let's set up
let's do it right now Luke we are and
you're you don't come up and I'm
following you already
James Lawrence we had him on the show
hit him up and uh send a demand letter
that they they've defamed you they've
accused you of something yeah that that
is that is untrue and absolutely untrue
because the thing is that they got me on
are are ridiculous they got me because I
showed a picture of all the Jets from uh
at the at the at the world economic
Forum meeting it was a legit photo and
they said no no it's a fake photo
because some people are sharing that
with another photo that's fake and I'm
like what that that makes no sense at
all the fact jerkers have been wrong
time and time again they are there to
stifle any kind of legitimate
conversations they're there to attack
comedy they're there to go after humor
I'm here just to make people laugh you
can interpret memes and pictures in so
many different ways and for them to
objectively say you are bad because you
made people laugh or you shared a meme
is absolutely ridiculous and it's
getting out of hand and it's hurting my
income and my bottom line is of course
if when people can't find me when people
are told not to follow me this is the
predominant way of of me making taking
my income this is how I make my
livelihood and you know
let's show a big middle finger to
Instagram go on at Luke we are change
and let's let's fight the algorithms
let's fight all this censorship and all
this bull crap because it's more
important than ever that our voices are
heard because they're trying to silence
us for a very specific here's the
important thing I'll add when you get
they say you know posted false
information or whatever by fact Checkers
that's actually not what a lot of it is
some of it's missing context which is
not false information and if that's the
case if Instagram has flagged your
account Luke saying you've posted false
information it's been reviewed by fact
Checkers you should go through your
posts because I I know for a fact some
of them were just like this post is
missing context in which case
Facebook or meta's automatic system
assumes if you get flagged it was for
posting false information that's a huge
error they issued a statement outside of
what the fact Checkers actually said I
think you would you you would win that
you said a demand letter and you'd win
in two seconds absolutely let's begin
the process right now because it's just
getting ridiculous I've been dealing
with this stuff for for over 12 years
now and it's only getting worse and
worse and worse and and this is well but
this is why I brought up Elon Musk
because actually I think it's starting
to get better Elon Musk is going on
Twitter and just laughing at the woke
employees that he's firing and he's
ragging on Democrats he's saying the
Democrats won't be investigated for
financial crimes it's just I mean this
is pretty good news you know uh there's
some questions about whether or not Elon
Musk can pull this off and Twitter might
actually go to business we'll see but
hey I'll take it right yeah I mean and
this is why I've been so optimistic
about Twitter again we should be a
little bit critical of Elon Musk but at
the same time he's promising something
that could change the game that could
make the world a better place just by
allowing people to talk to each other
just by allowing comedy on the platform
and this is why this whole ligma Johnson
thing brilliant smart it's making people
laugh it's silly it's ridiculous it's a
pun on on on on on something that people
should be making their jokes about
there's something interesting too
because I retweeted this um we have Noah
Sanders just super chatted that uh
quartering reported Elon is offering 10
over YouTube to larger channels uh I've
not heard that directly but I know know
he's tweeted someone said someone
tweeted that if Elon offered 10 percent
more than YouTube paid to content
creators those creators would move to
Twitter yes that is a fact Elon if you
made a video page for my Twitter profile
I would upload my content there and uh
and if you if you monetized it
when I post videos on Twitter I often
get more views than I do on YouTube but
there's just kind of no point for one my
videos are longer and you don't really
get anything for doing it if Elon Musk
does create a video monetization
function then then it's there people are
saying that there was a live skip during
my rant about censorship as well on the
platform but I don't know I got I gotta
I gotta you know fact check that as well
but if Elon Muslim if Elon Musk even
does less than than 20 of what YouTube's
doing I'm jumping because it's a it's an
alternative platform that that is
promising to follow basic guidelines and
to just allow speech that is free that
is legal and and that is worth any
amount of money that that is worth all
the money in the world right now because
if I'm able to just say whatever I want
if I'm not having to self-censor myself
if I'm not having to walk this tight
line if I'm able to be my true authentic
self and just speak freely from the top
of my mind that's that's a gift give me
less income give me half of what
YouTube's giving me I'll be on your
platform immediately right now well look
they're the same people the same people
that are doing this to speech are the
same people they do it in economics as
well that love to put their thumb on the
scale and pick winners and losers right
and so you know ultimately what we're
saying is let the marketplace of ideas
for Prevail exactly if an idea if an
idea sucks the people will let you know
sooner rather than later yeah stop
curating and treating us like small
children stop telling us what we should
be looking at stop trying to shove
corporate propaganda down our throat we
don't want to watch your bull crap we
don't want to watch the woke movies the
nonsense and all this nonsensical idiocy
we don't want any of that we want
legitimate real honest conversations and
that's something that we are being
denied of we're being denied the access
to laugh at things in order to not make
them as serious as they are we're being
denied the ability to find out what's
really happening in this world so we can
make the right decisions and not be
heard over and screwed over by the most
powerful people in this world and we're
beginning screwed over more and more by
these powerful special interests by big
Pharma and all these other criminals out
there that profit off of your ignorance
Society is becoming dumber and more and
and more stupid mainly because of this
censorship and it needs to end and it
needs to end now rumble's crashing yeah
too many people want to be there or not
or it could be a deliberate attack could
be that too if that's because because
now because now it's like okay YouTube's
not going to allow this Rumble list
let's all go to rumble and watch this
speech as of course YouTube is going to
be most likely censoring this is why the
guardian maybe just stopped hey guys we
got the uh
we got the live feed
is that Jared Kushner about five minutes
out it looks like Kushner
about five minutes out I could tell uh
because we just dropped 10 000
concurrent viewers everyone's jumping to
go watch hey keep watching our show you
guys well you know watch both at the
same time I do whatever you want we
don't lower the volume because
headphones YouTube used to have that
hardcore say anything you want not
anything obviously we're within the
bounds of law always but just this this
wild west is like 2006 you would say
anything to anybody and they would say
it back and you would have the most deep
intense painful enlightening
conversations with people about the
about real world issues about people's
feelings and it created Community it
created like a sense of strength Google
was so into it that they bought the
company like YouTube this is before
Google owned them and then I I then I
one of my friends got banned Warren 25
was the screen name and it was like the
first Banning on YouTube and I was
erratic about it there's Video Warren 25
smash band or something where I'm losing
my mind about it
um and I was concerned since once you
start getting corporate conglomeration
and that that the the history has shown
owned that the company will try and take
control once you start punishing people
for an expression for expressing an
opinion you're the bad guy you're the
Baddie okay that it's a it's a sure it's
as simple as that throughout human
history the people who censor other
individuals they're not the good guys
they're the bad guys thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time